this is a CBS News special report I'm
joining a couple in New York coming to
you as we have been every Thursday with
the newest weekly report on unemployment
claims the numbers have just come out
and it shows millions of Americans still
losing jobs after two months of the
coronavirus crisis CBS News business
analyst Jill Schlesinger joins us now
Jill good morning how bad are the
numbers this time well they are pretty
bad just under 3 million Americans are
filing for new unemployment claims now
this takes us up around 36 million
people for eight consecutive weeks the
number of people who are actually
already receiving unemployment that's
over 22 million so I guess the glimmer
here is that we are trending slightly
lower but boy these numbers are awfully
high we also have some fresh research
out Tony from NBER the National Bureau
of Economic Research predicting that 42%
of the layoffs now could be permanent
and that's what's worrying economists
across the country yeah so much for a
v-shaped recovery
we heard former Federal Reserve Chairman
Jerome Powell say this week that we're
in the worst recession since World War
two significantly worse in his words and
he thinks Congress may need to do more
on top of the nearly three trillion
they've already authorized to help
people get through this what's he
recommending well he really wants
Congress and the administration to write
more checks meaning Congress has the
power to spend while the Federal Reserve
it has the power to lend what is
different about that Powell believes
that we have avoidable catastrophes for
households and businesses if Congress
were to act there's going to need to be
additional lifeline sent out to
Americans
Powell himself cited some research from
the Fed which showed in February those
folks who are making $40,000 or less
those who had jobs one month later
40% of them were sidelined from the
labor market he is worried that those
people are going to need more government
a
assistance another big variable here is
what a consumers think of all this
there's no vaccine yet we don't know
what the timetable would be if people
don't feel comfortable spending they
won't go out what our consumer is
telling us about their willingness to
engage economically well we actually had
fresh research on this and it was
interesting to note that people who
receive stimulus checks they didn't
necessarily go out and spend that money
freely in fact 39% of them actually
saved it now I'm an old-time financial
planner I think that's pretty smart to
stockpile cash but the saving of money
is actually not good for the economy so
it is smart for your personal finances
but economists are worried that as
people are actually staying at home and
saving money that it could take longer
to start that economy up again all right
Joe Lester Forrest Jill thank you very
much